>>> IN OICH
CELEBRITY AND A PORN ARE
A LIVE BEAR HITTING TH F
INTO AN CIUS.THLETE AND T
REALAITLYN JENNER IS
AT THE CENTER OF THE RING.
SHE SAH SEANE ANNOCI H F
SHE MADEE TO BASN D RUMP AS CNNA
REPORTS.
CAITLYNR NOW JOINS US.
>>N HER FIRSINW ON FOX
NES CAE FOREPUBLIC
GOORLIFORNIA PRA TRUMP ZBLEFE T
IN A STATE THAT TRUM BY
NEARLY 30 POIN I2020.
JENNER, HER CAMPAIGN ADVISED BY
P TRYINGAL
BEYOND THE BASE.
>> I AL FOR THE WALLD CU WALL.
WE HAVRNIZED OUR
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM IN THE UNITED
STATES TO MAKE IT LE FOR
PEOPLE TO IMMIGRATE INTO THI
COUNTRY.
>>ROM HER AIRPNE HANGAR WI
NE, JENNERR GAVINE
FOR BEING OUT OF TOUCH.
EWSOM IS
POLITICIAN.OF RULES FOR
SACRAMENTO AND THERE'S ANO
SET UL
>> ReporIS ATTACKING
NEW SOME FORING
FRENCH LAUNDRY, EXCLUSIVE
COUNTRY SHALAS THE STATE
STRUGGLETH
RESTRICTIONS SINCEGIZED FO
THAT HELPED TOTHIXLL, QUALIFFOR
THE GOVERNORM BELIEVES
RNCACD REPUBLICAN RECAL
RE
AN-SD  I IMMIGRANTIS
MENT OWHBEHIND THIS RECALL.
THIS IS ABOUUR JOB, .
BUT IT AT ALL OF
>> FA
G LIST O
IN TOW, ADD SELF-FUNDEDLLIONAIA
ASAN?
>> PRETTY BOY Y.
>> OBALL-BUSTING BEAST.
Rr:IF
OR RECALL IN 200 N 100 CANDIDAT
PORN STAR MY CAREAND
THE INATOR, ARLDARZENEGGERWON.
Y FLIND RY
SINCE PASAWAY SINCE EY03.
MARY CAREY, THE  SSTILL HERE INS
ALREADY SAID SIL, YES O HE
RECALL.
NUMBER TWO, VOTE ON THE PLEMKE
I WA T MAVE RESTONLOTSS LAUGHEDD
TRUMP CAME DOWN
ESIDENT.
YET WE ALL KNOW HOW THAT TURNE
OUT.ULD CAITLYN JENNERLLNC NEXTA
>>TS OUTNUMBER
2-1. YOU'REIRTADERAL, SAOU'RE D
IN REPUBLICAN.BUT ALSO PLAYING
SUPPORT FOR DONALD TRUMP BEFORR.
RY TOUGH.
THE OTHER THING TO REMEMBER
HERE, JAKE, E'LAON'TNO SHE THIN
A LOT OF DIFFERENT
POLICIES S, YOU , ARNO SCHWARZE
WHEN HE RAN FO IN
2003, HE KINOF BEEN POKING IN P
INVOLVED IN BALLOT I. HAS LWORK
SH STATENOE SUPEO G IN
E  KYUNG, IN THE INTEWWITH SEAH
VERY LITTLE IN TERMS OF POLICYIY
DIDN'T DEMONST AICY
I COVERETHE RECALL IN Y SCHWARZ
LY ON, SEEMED
VERSED OPON NN
DOH. GOING TO BE VFFICULT FOR R
E IN MSHE SPOKE FROMWI HER
PRIVATE JEONNECT WITH T OF
IFNI REAL
FRUSTRATIONS.
ND ANGERSOME OF THESVI
IS WE PEOPLE TO NT
THEN
HOW DOESR FROME HOE
LEO JUST A FUNDAMENTAL QUESTION.
E  OIA OTO
DEMOCRATS, AS U HEARD MAEVE 2-OE
ER TNDOUS RISE
INDEPENDEN I STATE, IF
OK AT NO PARTY, D OTHER
RI
TEAM HAMMER AWAY AT THE POLICIES
NER R
REPUBLICANS HA.
THAT'S AOWERFUL TOOL HERE IN BE
MAEVE, JENNER THANNITY
AD DONE MORE  LBU H
DID DO SOME GOODOTGIVING SCIPOR
RAN  AT IS VERY IMPORTANT T
FORNIANS, AND ALSO JUST AS APOC
RELATING TO THE LGBTOMMUNIESPECY
AND SHE NOT O INTO
DETAIL ABOUT THAT LASTIGTHAT WIA
THING TO WOF THE MAIE IS
SHES NOT TRYING T
RAF AS THE T
CANDIDATE.
SHE IS RUNNING AS GOVERN,
WANTTOT T
ESPOLISHESSO SHEN'AL DELVE INTO
IL INT
AFTER THOSCO MADHE,  SHE NOTNS S
PLAYING IN